hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
as you guys already know Apple is having
their annual WWDC event next week Monday
June 22nd and we were personally
expecting Apple to update their 16 inch
MacBook Pro but I will just surprise
everybody this morning by releasing the
new updated 20/20 sixteen inch MacBook
Pro however it's a bit of a
disappointing upgrade because only one
thing has changed not the CPU like we
were expecting not Wi-Fi 6 but they're
just adding one more GPU option it's the
new 5600 M graphics card and it's
extremely expensive from the base model
it costs $800 to upgrade just to swap
out the GPU so you might be wondering
why it's so expensive and we are as well
so we just ordered this new MacBook Pro
and it should be here in two days so we
suggest not buying it yet wait for our
benchmark and gaming comparison videos
coming very soon and if you're not
already subscribed do it right now so
you don't miss out on those videos so
our question was what is so special
about this new 5600 M graphics card and
why is it so expensive well apparently
it has 75% more performance than the
5500 M and we also looked online for the
specs and we found out that the memory
bandwidth goes from 192 gigabytes per
second on the 5500 M up to a huge 394
gigabytes per second on the new 5600 M
graphics card and the reason for that is
because it uses HBM to memory which is
extremely expensive this is actually
what came on the old Vega 20 and the
interesting part is that this is the
first AMD Navi based graphics card to
come with HP m2 and to make it even more
interesting
that old Vega 20 option which actually
performed very well in some tasks only
had a hundred and eighty nine point four
gigabytes per second of memory bandwidth
so basically we may be looking at a
whole new beast
graphics option with the new 16 inch
MacBook Pro and another difference is
that it goes from 24 cores on the 5500 M
up to 40 cores on the new 5600 M this
basically means that we're gonna see a
huge boost in gaming performance as well
so make sure to subscribe for those
gaming tests all right so with this
brand-new surprise release what does all
of this mean and what should we be
expecting for the future first off we
should not expect a new 16 inch MacBook
Pro update until next year in 2021 when
it gets mini led now you might be a
little bit worried that Apple's gonna
update this 16 inch again in the fall
and that's because last year the 16 inch
MacBook Pro came only around 6 months
after the updated 15 inch in the year
before that Apple released the 15-inch
MacBook Pro with the 6 core processor
and then only four months later they
released the Vega 20 graphics option so
there is a chance that Apple could
release new CPU upgrade options on the
16 inch macbook pro but we find it
highly unlikely because we think the
next version of this is gonna come with
mini led and that's rumored to be
delayed until 2021 so based on that
people who are waiting until WWDC to buy
a 6 inch macbook pro can actually just
order one right now and the best part is
that the base 16 inch macbook pro is
actually on sale for $300 off using the
links in the video description below now
let's try to answer a very important
question why did an apple update the
CPUs as well well it could be because of
issues with trying to get enough supply
for the 10th gentians
but the current chips are still using
the old 14 nanometer process so there
shouldn't be any issues with that and we
recently compared the current 16 inch
MacBook Pro to the new HP omen which
comes with the 10th gen 6 core i7 which
we thought would come in this new 16
inch MacBook Pro but it didn't and we
noticed that in eek Mensch 5 there was a
huge difference in multi-core perform
but when it got to cinnamon jar 20 they
scored basically the same so my thought
is that Apple could have tests at the
east new chips and a 16 inch MacBook Pro
and they found that there really wasn't
much of a difference so they decided to
just hold off on that and stick with the
nine Chen because they can probably get
it for a lot cheaper and because of the
cooling system it might not be good
enough to take advantage of the better
tension chips instead Apple could be
waiting until next year when Intel
actually has real ten nanometer tension
chips which are gonna run a lot cooler
in the limited MacBook Pro chassis or
there's the very small chance that we
could see Apple implementing their new
ARM chips in the 16 inch MacBook Pro
which we honestly don't find likely now
there's one more very important thing
that we can learn from today's
announcement we know that the iMac is
getting redesigned and most likely
released next week at WWDC and this
tells us that this new 5600 M graphics
option is gonna be put into the smaller
iMac it's going to be the highest and
option for that iMac and on the other
side for the larger iMac we should
probably expect desktop graphics chips
like the 5500 X as the base and then the
5700 X which is the same as the 5700 XT
and maybe even a 5800 X option that
might come with HBM to memory and this
morning we also got a brand new leak
that we should expect face ID finally
coming to the redesigned iMac so
hopefully this video was very helpful to
you guys and don't forget that we
ordered that new MacBook Pro and we're
getting it in two days so make sure you
click that circle above to subscribe
because we're gonna be making thermo
benchmark videos and gaming videos as
well with that new 5600 M graphics
option thanks for watching guys and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]